bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv
spéciale grands champions avec jérôme le
mot france et lui remet c'est stéphane
alors on va voir un super champion russe
des années 50 70 et une carrière assez
longue carrière c'est long mais sa
carrière de joueur est plutôt situé dans
les années 50
voilà c'est alexander alexandrovitch
kotov qui restent connus pour la plupart
des amateurs pour son fameux livre
penser comme un grand maître qui en fait
un volume d'une trilogie évidemment de
trois livres dans laquelle il explique
sa fameuse technique du coup candidats
une selon laquelle il faut réfléchir un
coup candidats et ensuite calculer les
armes hors essence en fonction des coûts
candidats qu'on a sélectionné oui c'est
une technique qui voilà qui a été
débattue réutiliser modifié et assimilés
par de nombreux joueurs et de nombreux
auteurs qui ont suivi kotov qui au delà
du fait qu'il était un très fort joueur
est resté plutôt un auteur prolifique à
partir des années 60 70 et c'est pour ça
aussi qu'on a retenu son nom
alors on va voir une tout de suite une
image d'alexander kotov
voilà on le voit ici plutôt plutôt dans
ses jeunes années je suis pas
vingtaine d'années doit avoir une
vingtaine d'années il est né en 1913 à
tous là c'est une ville qui situe à
environ 200 km de moscou qui a été la
première fabrique d'armes tout l'a
instituée par pierre premier en 1712
donc c'était la spécialité delà de la
région c'est plutôt l'armement du reste
alexander kotov va faire des études
d'ingénieur comme beaucoup de joueurs
russes de l'époque de joueur soviétique
et son conte premier contact avec les
échecs en fait son premier contact avec
les jeux c'est d'abord le jeu de dames
et il apprend les échecs après à 14 ans
ce qui est relativement relativement
tard puisque la plupart des jeunes
champions déchus grands champions qu'on
a vu et qu'on verra dans l'histoire du
jeu ou comment çà cette eau vers 6-7 ans
oui comment ce relativement tard et
n'abandonne pas pour autant ses études
il se voit pas faire une carrière de
joueur d'échecs internationale ce qui
n'empêche pas d'avoir de très bons
résultats même dans ses jeunes années
dès avant la seconde guerre mondiale
puisque en 1939 il le perd le titre de
champion du rss face à bobigny qu'à la
dernière ronde
donc il a manqué de peu d'être champion
du rss dès 1939
pendant la guerre il obtient le titre de
grand maître soviétique
et puis sa carrière décolle
véritablement à partir de 45 à la
libération puisque en 1951 il fait
partie des premiers joueurs obtenir le
titre de grand maître international
d'échecs et en 1952 il à son meilleur
résultat qui est sa victoire à
l'intérieur un internat l'ancienne où il
marque 16 points et demi sur 20 et se
qualifie pour le zonal de zurich de
l'année suivante dans lequel il fait une
grosse contre-performance
et ça ça marque un petit peu un coût
d'un coup d'arrêt dans sa carrière on le
voit moins jouer après il remporte
encore des tournois il fait égalité
il remporte le tournoi d'hasting à
égalité avec gligoric quelques années
plus tard mais il se consacre ensuite
davantage à l'écriture c'est un auteur
très prolifique puisque entre 1953 et 58
par exemple il rédige une grande
biographie en quatre volumes d'alexander
ali quine le grand champion russe blanc
qui était pas très bien vu
à l'époque de staline est finie en
france il a fini en france et qui s'est
enfui comme beaucoup de russes à
l'époque surtout les russes blancs bien
sûr et quand on veut contribuer à
réhabiliter à les kings en se penchant
bien sûr sur l'extraordinaire créativité
du jeu d'ali keane plutôt que sur les
aspects politiques et ça permet de
réhabiliter cette figure importante des
échecs donc
de manière générale de toute façon on ne
peut pas dire que kotov été spécialement
rebelles vis-à-vis du pouvoir soviétique
c'est véritablement la personnalité dali
qui n'est le genre d'échec qui met en
valeur par le pas le russe blanc par
ailleurs kotov se montre volontiers très
et les en faveur du régime soviétique
puisque il rédige notamment un livre qui
s'appelle l'école des échecs soviétique
où il fait la promotion du régime
communiste en disant que la lady ctoire
soviétique aux échecs sont le résultat
logique de la culture socialiste qui a
été instituée par la révolution c'est
plutôt quelqu'un de très zélé c'est un
peu un apparatchik des échecs soviétique
et qui a contribué notamment par les
méthodes d'entraînement à maintenir la
pérennité de l'école soviétique donc
c'était un grand serviteur des échecs
soviétie positionnait fondateurs de la
pensée
d'apprentissage du jeu voilà voilà qui
est encore aujourd'hui
pendant le temps effectivement les
l'histoire du coup candidate c'est un
des méthodes d'apprentissage de la
maîtrise importante qui permet de
structurer la pensée pour jouer pour
pour savoir quoi jouer dans les
positions et l'ex1 les entraîneurs même
aujourd'hui se réfère encore à côte aux
fées à la notion de coût candidat c'est
un terme qu'on retrouve aussi bien dans
les livres que dans fortement notre
candidat en fait un candidat c'est toute
la question en fait qu'il y en a 2
s'impose
il peut y en avoir plusieurs mai
l'examen de
l'échiquier nous permettrait de voir
deux trois coups candidat voilà
d'éliminer ceux qui ne sont pas
intéressants et de se pencher sur le
calcul les arborescences concernant
chaque coup candidats pour déterminer à
la fin lequel offre les meilleures
chances toute la question étant de
savoir exactement et sa cote of le
président szysz pas forcément et
certains auteurs l'ont critiqué pour ça
c'est comment je fais pour repérer un
coup candidats oui parce que mais est ce
que ma façon de repérer les coûts
candidat sera la bonne et est ce qu'un
grand maître va pas repéré d'autres
coups candidats que moi en définitive
c'est peut-être toute la question de
cette méthode mais en tout cas il a
offert une un cadre une structure
structuration de la pensée chicken
rationnel il a été il a peut-être aussi
anticiper ce qui allait devenir après la
méthode informatiques classiques
d'élagage c'est à dire on crée des
arbres en informatique on voit tous les
coups mais on finit par élaguer larmes
on coupe les branches ont fait en mesure
qu'on la fonction évalue les positions
en fait non élu il propose de faire
c'est évidemment avec avec le cerveau il
part avec la machine
oui que les machines existait déjà mais
elle était alors balbutiements encore
l'époque dans les années 50 voilà donc
alexander kotov alors pour illustrer ce
grand champion est ce qu'on est ce qu'on
peut autre chose à dire peut-être sur la
fin de sa carrière ou non parce que sa
carrière en fête se termine assez tôt il
sent qu'il a qu'il a atteint ses limites
atteint le top qu'elle atteindrait qui
pourra pas aller plus haut que le zonal
il le vit vraiment commun comme un échec
et préfère se pencher sur les aspects
plus théorique la réhabilitation na li
qin la découverte d'une technique de
réflexion l'entraînement et tous les
aspects
lié aussi au développement des échecs en
urss il est très impliqué dans la
fédération soviétique d échec dès les
années 50
donc c'est plutôt quelqu'un qui va tu
vas être toute sorte de tuteur pour les
pour les futurs champions et qui sera un
entraîneur aussi pour pour tout la jeune
garde soviétique des années 60 70
alors ça fait une ça fait une très bonne
transition vers la partie du jour on
voit revenir sur le plateau un peu voilà
je vais passer à notre parti du jour
alors je me mettais en début de partie
voilà donc ce que tu disais il va être
un tuteur un peu pour la jeune garde et
là on est en plein dedans parce qu'on
est sur une partie entre kotov
est ce parce qu' à ce moment-là ce parce
qu'il est encore jeune oui puisque je
crois que la partie en 1959 donc
exactement c'est parce qu'il est encore
un jeune joueur qui a besoin de se faire
les dents tandis que kotov lui a déjà
une quarantaine d'années aux
championnats du rss on est au
championnat du rss qui est quand même à
l'époque ce sans doute l'antichambre du
championnat du monde
oui il ya quoi que fisher commencent à
pointer du nez parce que l'afficheur et
larsen qui viennent ajouter aux
championnats de l'urss alors le la
participation de l'occident mais c'est
vrai que le championnat du rss
c'est quasiment un championnat du monde
à l'époque donc on va voir une partie de
kotov inforad en pleine force de l'âge
parce qu'on est en 59 donc
il a quarante six ans 46 ans de 46 ans
que ce pas ce qui est encore tout jeune
59 qu'est la chasse parce qu'il est
devenue championne en 69 à desquelles il
devrait y voir il doit être en dessous
de 20 à gwadar 20 ans à peine 21 ans une
vingtaine d'années même moi je pense
qu'il doit avoir 18 ans parlant donc
bref en tout cas un jeune spassky pas
encore guéri pas encore le spassky qui
s'est cassé les dents sur petroci en
trois ans plus tard mais ce parce qu'ils
qui rencontre un vieux briscard du
circuit puisqu'il est déjà vice champion
du haut rhin c'est ce qu'ont utilisé en
1939 on est vingt ans plus tard et
toujours la low cost of il a écrit des
livres entre temps et il rencontre se
passe qui donc au top avec les blancs
démarrent cette partie avec ses 4 en
voyant comment le vieux briscard va
traiter le genou c'est ça voilà avec ce
qu'on sait catherine ici ce qu'on
appelle la partie anglaise est parti un
peu dévié ça peut dévier on peut rentrer
dans des gourbis dames avec des cats
c'est ce que fisher a accepté de jouer
dans son match face à spa ce qui pour ne
pas jouer des 4 puisqu'il voulait pas
jouer des cas pour pas ce dernier il ya
eu sinon ils jouent et le cas tout le
temps mais il a voulu changer mais pour
pas jouer d'état puisqu'il a dit fier
que les poules mouillées des quatre il a
joué ses 4 mai ce qui peut revenir dans
des positions à ouverture des quatre
alors ces quatre cavaliers six points de
plus qui va se passer ici d'ailleurs
qu'elle est si ce qu'avait laissé 3g 6
voilà on rend dans une partie indienne
la couleur est annoncée des 4 es fou g7
estonienne leucate donc invasion du
centre par les blancs et les noirs vont
essayer de contre attaquer ce centre à
distance on a déjà le foot en embuscade
on va tôt ou tard jouer des six sans
doute de 5
pardon pas au 6 mai le seigneur pour
faire déjà des pressions au centre voire
6 5 et essayer soin de bloquer le centre
soit de l'ouvrir et de faire vivre ce
fou et de le contre attaquer à distance
et si on bloque le centre les noirs
nationale qui a le droit
l'idée ici c'est de laisser les blancs
occuper les centres ce qui ne veut pas
forcément dire d'ailleurs complètement
le contrôler mais en tout cas l'occupé
essayer de fixer la chaîne de pions et
puis l'attaqué par des poussées latéral
je la dis comme ces cinq éventuellement
f5 pour justement faire exploser ce
centre blanc c'est ce qu'on va voir dans
cas lors des 6es la f3 alors ça c'est un
coresponsable puisque f3 n'est pas le
coup le plus usité on peut dire que nous
plus vite et sans doute que bf3 parfois
faux chiffres eux deux
variante un peu peu subtile aussi et f3
en rentre dans la variante ses miches
donc 26000 qui a été notamment beaucoup
joué par karpov lui-même y compris
contre kasparov d'ailleurs qui est une
variante extrêmement solide et
extrêmement positionnelle face à
l'estonienne ont joué trois tout de
suite on consolide énormément le pion
ici le pion au clac donc la case de 4
qui est déjà protégé aussi par le
cavalier mais on consolide et on va
avoir un développement à base de fouet
trois bases de calcul de rampants et
puis c'est en août qui avait ses seins
parfois et après peut-être orient d3 et
rosie et un développement lent mais qui
est très très difficile à percer du côté
noir
si les noirs veulent être agressif c'est
difficile d'être de l'être contre cette
structure là qui est extrêmement solide
donc petit rock fouet trois mythique
souffle but important puisqu'il est de
cases noires face à une structure ici
sur casse blanche donc structure ici
chaîne de plan complémentaire du fou la
poussée f3 affaibli comme une telle
diagonale importante pour le roi blanc
oui c'est la déveine al h41 celle là
celle là est problématique dans un
premier temps et puis une autre de
diagonale qui peut être problématique
dans un deuxième temps qui est la
diagonale g 1 à 7
c'est vrai puisque après le petit rock
on peut supposer que les blancs vont
faire le petit rock
après le petit rock le roi se trouve sur
cette case g1 est donc en ligne de mire
éventuelle d'un fou d'une dame / cases
noires voilà exactement tout à fait sur
des thèmes qu'il faut garder à l'esprit
bon n'est pas encore là ya pas de
véritable danger pour l'instant tout ça
est bien construit et pas d'échec à
crème ou 5 mais ça y est déjà on en est
même plus complet on pourrait il peut il
ya des variantes d'ailleurs
les noirs cavaliers h5 et on se retrouve
avec un petit échec l'a parfois pénible
à gérer le fonds pourrait revenir
extérieur donc 5
voilà en tout cas la question se pose
les noirs elles peuvent menacer de
prendre peuvent aussi menacé de jouer
ces 6 puis plus tard des cinq parfois
pour ouvrir le centre parce que ce coût
est quand même un courant pas on n'a pas
développé de pièces en jean ça on a
perdu du temps alors qu'on a déjà évoqué
ici donc c'est ouvrir le centre parfois
si les blancs sont trop lents et bien on
peut se retrouver en danger avec le roi
au centre ici donc faut faire attention
donc blocage voilà en jouant des cinq on
enlève toute possibilité tactique
précoce dans la partie mais on a fixé
notre structure de pions donc elle est
déjà elle est déjà fixée donc les noirs
savent quoi faire et ça veut ce qui
s'est passé au centre
comment la structure effigie au centre à
l'effigié il ya plus de mobilité donc un
des plans de leurs peuvent est peut être
de pousser f5 assez vite et de ne pas
laisser les blancs les étouffer en
jouant gk par exemple ce genre de choses
on peut remarquer aussi que le fou blanc
de cases noires est complémentaire de la
chaîne de pions oui en revanche le fouet
fin fait un petit peu peine à voir pour
le moment
oui parce qu'elle n'a pas beaucoup
d'avenir un ouvrier ruthin il bute se
fout là contre ses propres pions donc ce
foulard a du mal à vivre un pour
l'instant il est en attente que le la
structure depuis on change de couleur
alors alors un coup intéressant dans
cette position de la part de spassky c5
alors c'est celle pose une vraie
question noire parce que si évidemment
sur ces 5 on peut envisager de prendre
en passant alors surprendre passé on ne
peut gagner du temps de développement
par exemple par cavalli prend on peut
aussi rapproché un pion du centre avec
la possibilité de jouer des cinq très
vite et créer une ouverture du centre
extrêmement rapide
étant donné que le développement est
quasiment fini du côté noir
et que les fous des perspectives ça peut
s'avérer extrêmement dangereux d'autant
plus que les blancs ne sont pas prêts de
rock et oui bah oui pas aller que le fou
et enfin une cavaliers g1 sont encore
sur leur case de départ
oui alors en plus si on prend à ses 6
après devait prendre n'a pas envie de
croquer grotte parce que il ya la
colombe et qui est ouverte plus on fout
dernière qui peut se réveiller
ça peut faire mal donc ce coup est joué
au bon moment parce que il finalement il
fixe totalement le centre ça devient
très dur pour les blancs d'envisager une
attaque à l'aide d'amis qui ça c'est
possible mais va falloir jouer tombé 1
va falloir jouer à trois des quatre pour
essayer d'ouvrir le jeu avec peu de
perspectives finalement parce que même
si on fait un échange on voit pas trop
comment on poursuit donc
donc c'est un jeu qui bloque alors quand
on sait que aux échecs et notamment des
dispositions fermes et quand on a bloqué
le centre on peut commencer à envisager
très sérieusement attaqué sur les élèves
parce que y aura pas de surprise au
centre donc ça va être l'heure de très
rapidement de jouer des cavaliers 5 km 8
ou f5 et de lancer des attaques alors il
vaut mieux attendre aussi que le roi
choisit son camp avant d'aller trop loin
dans la taxe sinon on va avoir un roi
tenue et un vin blanc qui peut passer de
l'autre côté
bon bref il faut quand même aussi savoir
quelles adresses va être donné à noter
aussi que sur ces structures les noirs
peuvent aussi envisager des assisses b5
sacrifice et de pions des sacrifices de
plomb pour ouvrir le jeu elle dame est à
voir du jeu
voilà donc c'était un coup
un bon coup c5 est sûre pour ce type de
position
kotov évidemment veiller de l'expérience
comme il voit ses possibilités bijoux gk
tout de suite ça c'est fort au signe
parce que j'ai quatre maintenant l'idée
c'est de dire ben vas-y pour f5
parce que moi je tient parfaitement la
case f5 voire même pourquoi pas jouer g5
et verrouiller la case f6 empêcher f5
pour prendre et 6 et pourquoi pas moi
même commencé à attaquer aussi un droit
c'est tout à fait faisable en tout cas
en faisant ça je dis que mais je
justifie mon cou instrument encore plus
parce que nous sommes il protège le sens
mais il protège une expansion est un
droit et puis sites à bloquer le sentais
que tu envisagé d'attaquer allait lever
c'est moi qui attaquent en premier par
contre ça veut dire que mon roi
maintenant j'ai donné un peu son adresse
c'est à dire que soit je reste au centre
soit jouer à gauche oui parce que je me
vois mal faire le petit rock dans ces
conditions ici ce ne sera qu ici avec
quand même beaucoup de courants d'air
autour de roy camille 8
ça c'est logique c'est ce qu'on avait
dit alors on évite de se faire chasser
le carré mais surtout on peut préparer
f5 on n'a pas du tout peur de ce coup
parce que l'ouverture ici prise prise
prise et c'est avec le fou qui sort nous
donnerait un jeu magnifique un pur f3
qui serait mauvais donc fcn qui est
toujours dans l'air du temps et
là maintenant par contre c'est presque
une discussion théorique autres dirai ce
que j'ai 4 et un bon coup ou pas ça va
dépendre des fêtes que fcn qui est bon
ou pas c'est une affaire de grandes
lettres h4 non ça c'est poursuit
l'attaquent
c'est très responsable alors ça évite
s'est vite déjà l'échec damage 4 voilà
même s'il n'était pas trop à craindre
parce qu'un souhait de défendre très
tranquillement voilà mais c'était
surtout une autre ambition c'est
d'ouvrir la colonne h rando à la colonne
âge parce qu'on a déjà la turquie bien
placée pour l'attak
finalement on n'a pas marqué encore mais
le centre étant bloquée ben c'est pas si
mal pour les blancs h5
on peut jouer dam des deux on peut aller
échanger les fous et après avoir échangé
les fous et avoir pris ici et bien la
dame va attaquer ici et le roi risque se
retrouver sous le feu des pièces et
demie c'est classique et ça peut être le
moment pour le noir de jeu quand même f5
oui on peut quand même contre attaquer
c'est peut-être souhaitable parce que
les blancs déjà pousser leurs pions ghl
et le roi oui le jeu noir allèles dame
est peut-être un petit peu lent vous
avez tout à fait le jeune aura le
général d'alger risque d'être lent et
puis fcn peut menacer aussi f4 pour
boucher finalement parce que si on n'a
que deux pions contre 2 c'est très dur
d'attaquer en fait parce que dès qu'on
essaie de faire une rupture hop on
bloque et ça devient difficile de passer
bon en contrepartie de quoi on pourrait
avoir un coût de casement ici totalement
un muret dans ses propres pions oui mais
ce serait le cas aussi du fou de cases
blanches
oui c'est vrai aussi c'est aussi tout à
fait donc mais f s'inquiéter
il fallait réfléchir c'est tout à fait
un coup joint d'imposition au lieu de
quoi c'est parce qu'ici pas encore
suffisamment aguerri sans doute joué le
coup à 6 alors c'est aussi dans l'esprit
du jeu de cette ouverture à 6 l'idée ça
peut être d'empêcher d'éventuelles
arrivées 5 pourquoi pas mais surtout de
préparer avec ou pas un tour b vite
derrière plus tard ou très vite de jouer
le coup b5 p5 pour ouvrir le jeu enlevé
en cas de prise ici un soutien de du
pion des cinq libéré le pion c5 et mais
surtout ouvrir les colonnes ici de façon
attaquer là alors jusqu'où effectivement
l'adresse durable en devient
problématique parce que si je peux aller
ni à gauche parce que l'un colonnes sont
ouvertes là ni à droite parce que mon
but c'est l'attaqué il faut laisser le
roi au centre bon temps que le centre
est fermé c'est pas forcément une
mauvaise idée mais il faut garder ça en
tête on accepte d'avoir un roi au centre
c'est toujours l'idée on est l'idée est
désagréable même si concrètement on a du
mal à l'accepter ça plus souvent tout à
fait tout et 3 alors forcément coûter 3
est logique même si le fou ici bouché
par ses pions en bien par transparence
ici en quelque sorte on contrôle f5 ses
rangs le cas de f5 on peut prendre avec
ce plan est le fou du coup vie il vit
tout de suite il peut même s'échanger
contre ce fou ici
donc ce qui était un mauvais fou fini
par s'échanger avec une bonne pièce
c'est pas plus mal
puis on peut imaginer que les blancs ont
dans l'idée de jouer leurs cavaliers g1
ou g2 puis angers 3 pour y soutenir l'
attaque et c'est mieux que le fou passe
d'abord amélie est sûre tout à fait on a
d'abord sorti le fou g2 ensuite j'ai
trois et on a aussi un cavalier à
l'attack et qui va soutenir aussi h5
soutenir enfin contrôler la case f st on
a envie toujours nos vingt cavaliers
angers 3 1 bien sûr
alors si en plus on peut la voir
derrière des purs avancer on a une belle
position d' attaque mais la b5 alors
c'est bien ce parce qu'il perd pas trop
de temps non plus il n'a pas il a choisi
de ne pas jouer 5 mai d'attaquer l'autre
côté en tout cas il perd pas de temps à
regarder il donne un pion c'est à dire
qu'ici on est sur un vrai sacrifice puis
on prend puis on prend cavaliers ou fou
prend peu importe on a donné un pion oui
mais on a ouvert la colonna et on a
libéré le pion c'est ce qui peut être
aussi intéressant parce que ceux qui ont
peu plus ces attaques et le fou gagner
de l'espace
ça peut libérer la casse et 5 pour un
cavalier pourquoi pas donc ça donne
beaucoup de jeu pour le pion et surtout
la problématique de savoir où va le roi
se pose de plus en plus parce que s'ils
connaissent ils ouvrent ici faudra pas
tirer rock de ce côté mais pour ça que
cotto a choisi de ne pas prendre ce pion
de gambie c'est un brigand bits et je
vous donne des deux alors dam des deux
c'est toujours dans l'idée
il y aura des communes conséquent
coteaux fille continue il a contre
attaqué il attaqué sur les lois y vivent
ou d'amd 2 qu'est ce qu'il veut faire et
bien ils veulent éliminer le défenseur
endurant s'échanger h5 prises et ça sera
la dame ensuite qui va venir soutenu par
la tour faire un échec mortel avec sans
doute peut-être une attaque de maths
c'est c'est direct mais c'est elle c'est
le plan classique le changer en un
schisme le jeu n'est pas caché non non
il ya pas de l'effet de louvoiement ce
qui paie d'ailleurs c'est un des trucs
pénible dans cette variante pour les
joueurs d'aston yen qui savent pas trop
quoi faire contre c'est que le plan
dublin hyper clair on sait pas quoi
faire pour l'empêcher en fait ça va très
vite c'est vrai très vite ouais mais
prend ses 4 bon voilà donc là ça obligés
au blanc de reprendre dans l'intérêt qui
peut être d'avoir pris avec le foot
france et qu'on a moins de défense sur
la case f5 déjà aussi donc si le coin
scène devient plus intéressant pour les
noirs et puis le fou ou c4 et en l'air
le fossé la tête en l'air une autre idée
et c'est ce que fait ce pas ce qui c'est
tout effectivement qu'il ya les 17 cas
les 17
olala avec ici le cavalier l'idée c'est
de venir en b6 et on gagne un temps sur
le fou il faut que le four partent donc
éventuellement pousser le puck et en
fait on pourra jouer ce fameux coup c4
qui contrôle la case d3 donne de l'air
aux cases noires permet d'avoir des
avants de postes éventuelles
et qui en conjonction avec une tour but
et c'est donc du juge courroye au noir
pendant sur les dames hcm côté continue
son plan oui comme c'est direct je dis
pas non c'est parce que tu bricole là
moi je vise le roi et en attendant
j'avance bien ce parce qu'ils continuent
mais tout ça est bien là quand même
cavale et v6 tranquillement food et 3 on
revient d'être alors une main les blancs
les noirs en gagner un peu de temps pour
développer leur clavier ils ont fait
bouger le fou puis il a dû revenir c'est
bien hélas à 5
alors voilà un coup responsables aussi à
5 alors l'idée des 5 peut être de
libérer le fou
ces huit sur a6 pour s'échanger quand on
me fout les trois pourquoi pas ou pour
soutenir la poussée c4 une fois qu'on a
joué ses claques pour soutenir le pion
c'est tout à fait envisageable aussi ça
peut être aussi une possibilité d'éviter
rien du tout donc voilà cinq ans qu
encore une fois c'est un coût qui est
cohérent ouais mais qui semble un petit
peu un petit peu lent un petit peu lent
par rapport à l'imminence de berlange et
les liens sont déjà là alors qu'on sait
pas trop on voit pas encore clairement
quelle quelle pression noire existe de
ce côté là c'est pas très claires donc
auto s'il continue il prend h progressis
et regarder dans très importants de ce
parce qu'ici il faut bien comprendre il
fait froid voilà alors ça c'est
important parce que s'il fait 6 passes
qui l'avait fait à je prends ce qui est
possible problème c'est salé selon roy
noir totalement fermé il peut pas sortir
parce qu'il est bloqué par ses propres
pièces ici donc c'est très dangereux
parce que préfou h6 la menace fou prend
et damages 6 crée une menace de maths
alors que en prenant du pian f
on se ménage ici une petite sortie pour
le roi ouf c'est que ça donnera de l'air
ça donnera un coup de plus par contre ça
risque ça peut donner
le pion h c'est à dire que en échange de
quoi on peut donner le pion ici de
défense c'est tout à fait possible mais
il vaut mieux d'une un pion que le roi
en tout cas ça fait peur évidemment
devant une tour comme ça devant une
batterie de prendre du plomb h avec un
aura un peu étouffée c'est quand même
très dangereux y en a beaucoup des
matches comme ça on en a mis plein à
noter aussi que les blancs deux
possibilités après une
un fois si si si pour mettre la pression
soit en cas de prise prisé mais aussi la
possibilité de mettre la dame en h2 ici
concernés une batterie et on attaque
aussi h7
c'est d'ailleurs ce que va faire kotov
parce qu'ils jouent dommage de bain
exactement tout à fait et il menace il
veut dommage de tout de suite prendre un
set il aurait qu il aurait pu tenter d
une fois ci mesdames d'un match 2 est
encore plus fort sans doute pas ça crée
une menace alors que faut aussi se crée
une menace en plusieurs temps la menace
est direct menace d'un proche cet échec
gagnant groupe y on est surtout un roi
qui devient un endroit faible qui
commence à bouger alors qu'il avait
l'air d'être bien à l'abri au début donc
ce qui est pas forcément de but donc le
coup suivant de spa ce qui est logique
cavaliers f6 on revient maintenant que
le travail d'ouverture avec le pion
effet c'est fait on revient le khalife 6
pour défendre la case h7 ça paraît
logique on n'a pas peur de coups comme
g51 gens pour soi et cavaliers voilà sur
gsm gars le classique cavaliers h scène
qui en bouche
l'action de la dame qui ne peut plus
tapés sur h7 on est bien protégé par le
clan justice ça va être lent pour les
blancs d'essayer de déloger ce cavalier
c'est possible mais il va falloir faire
des plans à base de cavaliers de cavalli
g3 tout ça est lent les noirs auront le
temps de les serrer l'étau
les noirs ont le temps de faire beaucoup
de choses à notre temps il faut éviter
des plantes roland donc kotov moyens
d'augmenter la pression ils attaquent
simplement de façon simple et efficace
tu as voyages 3 sur ses neiges au likoud
développement du cavalier et simplement
mais j'avais visé la case g5 puisque
j'attaque le pillage cette 6e qui on
bouge ça m'arrange parce que s'il vient
à six il sera tôt ou tard sous le feu
il faut droit même si le cavalier les
suffrages de l'enlever pour que la
pression augmente on peut même envisager
de venir eux aussi sain parce qu'on est
protégé partir des 5
un échange du pion central contre le
curage 7 c'est pas plus mal ça va m
leroy totalement dans les courants d'air
voilà donc la menace est claire et on ne
sait pas trop comment faire pour
l'éviter
on est toujours là donc dams est alors
dame 7,2 spassky bon alors ça c'est pas
terrible terrible
à la limite si vous voulez défendre la
7e et on pressent que moi j'aurais
presque préféré tour hausse est en fait
un oui je préfère défendre avec la tour
parce que la dame ici bloc du coup va
gêner la tour c'est le ciel veut passer
c'est le coulisses et puis finalement
c'est pas trop ce que fait la dame ici
quoi par rapport à l'import ça s'est
passé sur les sur des cases noires qui
sont occupées déjà par les pions et par
des pièces ouais c'est pas c'est pas
terrible terrible bon ceci dit ces dames
qui dit qui est défensive
mais à choisir finalement se demande si
tu auras cet été pas plus peut-être un
tout petit peu plus un peu plus précis
un peu plus précis je sais pas un peu
moins un peu moins lourd comme parce que
mobiliser une dame comme ça
défensivement c'est un peu dommage alors
qu'havas lieu 2 alors là on voit bien le
briscard qui manoeuvre puisque il ya
presque alors se fout une petite action
puisque par transparence contrôler cette
ce fouillis clairement actifs à tout
moment il peut venir s'échanger ici ce
cavalier prêt à bondir angers 5 et il y
avait encore ce cavalier qui jouait pas
dans la tacc donc en jouant ce coup
kotov des montres qui sait aussi
recycler ces pièces pour augmenter au
maximum son efficacité il vient de 2
qu'est ce qu'il veut faire
il veut par exemple venir en g3 commencé
à contrôler lui-même des cases d'attac
c'est vrai ça peut être extrêmement
extrêmement utile oui je joue à je pense
que c'est une fête c'est ça qui sait ce
qui menace à tout simplement parce que
il peut avoir comme arrière-pensée de
placer sa tour à angers un moment donné
il veut peut-être aussi plus tard s'il
veut te mettre toutes les pièces à
l'attak a racheté l'autre tôt ici est
sacrifié le cavalier g35 en ouvrant la
colonne voilà exactement effectivement
signé deux cavaliers avec 5 prises prise
est tout de suite tour g1 est en attaque
attaque le rang avec l'image du foot
c'est très dangereux donc tomber 8 de ce
parce qu' on comprend le plan de
passe-passe qui mais qu'est ce que c'est
lent regardez il ya toujours pas une
seule menace sert même ce coup qui est
ce dû aux actifs parce qu'il attaque le
pion de v2 par transparence avec lequel
il va falloir encore jouer le cavalier
pour pouvoir attaquer véritablement le
pion alors que de l'autre côté toutes
les pièces sont déjà au contact et il ya
déjà beaucoup de calculs à faire pour
essayer d'éviter des combinaisons
dangereuse calais g31 kotov a pas peur y
rajoute sa dernière pièce et on est
quasiment au niveau optimal de situation
des pièces blanches sont quasiment
toutes en position de bondir dans le
camp ennemi avec ici un potentiel
attaque énorme presque plus que c'est
tour la kippa l'attaquent même le
poulain alain mythique peugeot in tirol
ici en cas de crise et on devrait même
envisagé de prendre avec ce pion parce
qu'on peut jouer g5 et puis après en
poussant la le fou qui a attaqué h7
donc il ya que la tour là qui est pas l
attaque alors que de l'autre côté il ya
quoi il ya rien du tout en fait y'a même
pas une
il ya même pas un contact c'est pas
grand chose pour l'instant si ce n'est
le petit poucet c4 alors là tout petit
poucet ces quatre attaques le fou très
bien effectivement le foot attaquer si
les noirs vont surtout pas donner le fou
de casement ici contre la pauvre parce
que même si on peut prendre le fou
latour pénètre peu enfin fait pression
en deuil on ne peut pas pénétrer parce
qu'on admire 1er mai on aurait donné
notre food attaque contre un cavalier
qui joue pas et où par exemple
l'allemagne puis une autre fois on n'a
surtout pas envie de donner il est très
très bien donc sur ces 4 on est quand
même ici avec une toute petite
menacèrent si les blancs recule alors
cavalli à 4 hélas la menace
effectivement sur deux existants alors à
noter ici que si le fou vient sur cette
case en à la dame aussi qu'ils
contrôlent oui mais le contrôle plus
plombé de par contre un contrôle public
des données la corne au petit matin vaut
mieux vaut bien un pur en force et deux
pour essayer de ne plus respirer parce
que là et quand même un petit peu
engoncé derrière sa ligne de pions c'est
parce qu'ils décident de faire un
sacrifice au centre exact sacrifie le
cavalier b alors il s'accroche mais
voilà alors cirque là le problème c'est
que ce parce qu'il faut qu'il a fait ça
qu'est-ce qui fait il peut pas jouer il
aurait bien aimé jouer à la cap parce
que ça attaque b2 avec lecavalier et la
tour
bon il peut pas le fou simplement je
prends les gagner une pièce il met pas
besoin d'attaquer
il suffit juste d'échanger tous
maintenant j'ai gagné la finale bon
qu'est ce qui peut faire d'autres
circulent cavaliers ici belle bouche
sont fous donc il n'a pas trop de casse
donc comment faire pour créer une petite
menace ici c'est pas terrible donc ils
décident de d'y aller avec grands moyens
parce que sinon elle sera écrasée en
fait la menace qu'ils avaient g5 est
trop forte
la menace aussi cavalier 5 peut arriver
très vite
avec comme tu le disais pourquoi pas
mais on peut même envisager marocain
s'est passé presque où on peut envisager
en roi f2 ou un roi 2 ou un roi des deux
suivis de tours et un disque genre de
coups bon mais choisi de sacrifier au
centre calvé d510 donne quand même dû
contre jeu un peu de contre je veux
puisque on commence à attaquer mais deux
menaces b2 après la reprise
la tour et fuites menacera aussi le
piouf trop voilà c'est à dire que
celui-ci mutas alors pour l'instant
c'est chaud à cause de ça oui mais
effectivement si on prend un jour ici on
peut commencer à attaquer un peu le pied
droit puis surtout il en incombe et de
s'empresser de le prendre ici après
prendre et c'est au tour promet de voilà
donc les noirs en fait jouer leur va
tout pour éviter de se faire totalement
écrasée dans un ou deux coups de se
lancer dans une attaque alors on a quand
même deux pions pour le cavaly ça c'est
bien c'est déjà pas mal
une tour qui commence à être active et
des possibilités effectivement de
prendre encore un pion ici pourquoi pas
d'attaquer le pion f3 pourquoi pas de
profiter de ce clou âge du fou sur la
dame
pourquoi pas de faire un certain nombre
de possibilités ici même si le potentiel
d'attac noir et blanc pardon est
toujours bien présent mais s'il ya donc
ça reste très dangereux donc d'ailleurs
kg 5
car il est simple la menace simplement
car les pointes cette attaque tour et
cavalli c'est durant l'un donc à chis de
la part des noirs alors le problème
d'eau h6 évidemment c'est que ça met le
pion sur la couleur du fou blanc est
donc ce pion il suffit de retirer le
cavalier qui est sûre la casse g5 pour
que le pion à chis soitec et maintenant
elle sait ce qu'elle fait
voilà donc ici cavaliers leucate menaces
prises ici en abscisse menace faut
prendre si ce qui fait donc deux choses
là je sais pas si nous coucher cinq
étaient envisageables ici parce que je
suis en train de venir admettant que le
que les noirs ici joue g5 pour essayer
de bloquer toute attaque sur le pion à
chiyah les problèmes en leurs divisions
et aller
hélas 15 et 16 cavaliers preuve six
cavaliers h 5 ou même oui bien sûr piale
fou et puis le faut
ah oui on perd là tout est en fait un
peu peur dans la tour un échec par
exemple d'emprunt et ouais on peut
envisager
on peut aussi simplement protégé f3 on
peut mais attention il ya une menace et
fourrages cet échec aussi d'en prendre
tout un oui il faut parer les chèques et
après la dame prend la tour il ya aussi
la menace du jury qui avait eu cinq
attaques d'un me fous il ya beaucoup de
possibilités de pénétration ici dans le
camp ennemi donc câblée 5e 4 et qu'elle
prend des cinq seller ça fait trois
pions quand même pour la pièce donc le
temps dans la flore que kotov comme
justifie son attaque parce que trois
pions pour la pièce une tour actes il
est noir commence à respirer commence à
avoir du jeu s'il arrive à pousser leurs
pions sans trop y libérer le fou g7
ah oui ça se peut exact rapidement se
retourner ça peut vite se retourner donc
fou prend h61 donc là il faut y aller
maintenant il faut profiter de la
position des pions à 6 et là alors ils
peur des menaces qu'on me faisait cinq
attaques la dame et la dame est
maintenant de venir en rage cette série
shake si on prenait du fou on laisserait
la dame revenir prendre et protéger le
roi donc une possibilité c'est d'enlever
le food de l'attak donc là les noirs n'y
vont pas par quatre chemins et joue
calais b 4 en 10 ans mais coûte c'est
simple moi en tout cas
j'attaque le fou qui ne peut pas bouger
parce que si le faux bouge c'est la dame
d'accord claire donc là les blancs n'ont
pas trop le choix il faut que l'attak
avance fou g5 seriez kotov libère la
colonne h pour saddam à noter qu'on peut
pas jouer il faut être si suri fils
puisqu'il ya cavalier est fou emprise
ici donc ça c'est pas possible et
cavalier prend ces deux ne fonctionne
pas bien non plus alors si les noirs
font cavalier prend ses deux échecs
c'est possible il ya échec
simplement on prend parce que avec le
fou en attaque toujours la dame donc
s'il est noir reprennent en c2 et bien
simplement te l'ont fait fou prend de
cette attaque
la tour f 8 et aussi le pion des six par
exemple tout reprend f3 a l'air bien
puisqu'on on récupère simplement un pion
ici et on peut envisager simplement
qu'ils allaient prendre des six avec le
fou s'est vite qui est attaquée ou alors
en qu'est-ce qu'on peut envisager aussi
on peut aussi envisager de jouer tourbe
et un pour venir pénétrer en 18 et
clouer le fou sur le roi le roi est
toujours mal à l'aise de toute façon en
7e position à noter que si le roi bouge
af 7 on a toujours des menaces de soi
deux des six avec échec de prendre le
fou soit aussi des menaces angers 5
échecs toujours avec la fourchette 1
voilà donc dans le c7 damage cet échec
n'ont finalement je vous aime c'est
cette année sur damas cet échec est
hélas très joli coup de god of
puisqu'ils jouent le coutour h6 très
classique le fou g7 est clouée sur le
roi donc la nouvelle sur le roi tourage
6 et la menace bien sûr de prendre le
pion ici d'un hacker chèque avec échec
donc cavalier français deux échecs et la
wka f1 simplement pour kotov
à noter que le coup maintenant qu'est
l'e3 ne marche pas puisqu'il ya le fou
pendant que muscade et là il ya une
menace noir c'est encore une fois s'est
prolongée 6 on allait s'y prendre et si
ce n'est pas si noir prenez ici la tour
par exemple mais simplement faire une
dame projet 6 2 où va le roi parce qu'il
peut pas venir c'est que tu fous 1,8
soit toujours un échec et réclame qu'il
faut revenir sur g8 ici et là tout
simplement
on peut tenter encore revenir sains et
suroît f7 maintenance et l'abscisse tous
réussissent échec alors on ne peut pas
prendre avec le fou puisqu'on est
protégé à la fois du fou il cavaliers
donc il faut que le roi rouge
et si le roi bouge ou sait qu'il peut
aller 6 voire 7 c'est le fou qui saute
et silva a eu huit autres possibilités
d'un cavalier prend des six on peut
encore faire cavaler prendre des six est
là et peut faire parce qu'attention si
on va sur les quinze mois on va prendre
un échec a découvert on va pouvoir
n'avait qu'un échec à la découverte où
on peut venir en f1 f7 sur un échec pu
prendre la dame et enfin tout ce qu on
fait un la cdc est archi faux culs mais
il faut donner la table
et si on remonte en afs est on en perd
le fouet fuite et un tour ça va faire
beaucoup et le roi que ne craint rien
fait ici et bizarrement mais finira la
dame peut pas venir faire des chèques
même le fou peut pas venir ya le pion
qui gêne donc c'est des noirs qui vont
se faire mater en premier donc ça va
très vite donc cavalier des quatre de la
part de ce pass qui en venant des cats
parce qu'il a essayé de colmater impoli
brèche
y contrôle des cases on a vu que la case
de 6 pouvait jouer un rôle aussi donc il
revient un tout petit peu en défense en
fait un ce caillou revient en défense
très clairement et a refusé d'aller
prendre la tour et là ça y est c'est
l'heure d'un projet six échecs
donc là c'est très dur pour ce pas ce
qui s'est déjà sonné le roi est en train
de s'effondrer totalement et après roy
chez vis très simplement damage cet af 7
et enfin ici simplement qu'à les prendre
les schistes tout de suite échec
voilà alors il ya pas de casier pas de
cool ya plus de coûts pour le roi la
seule façon de parler de maths
la salle est de donner la dame voilà on
peut pas venir non plus 1,7 à cause du
fou on ne peut pas monter à cause de la
tour on ne peut pas l'élan g8 cause de
la dame
donc il ya pas le choix faut prendre le
cavalier donc ça gagne adam et après
tour prendre les 6 es encore le coup
cabello six petits pièges encore de
spassky attention il menace pour la
suite et peut-être un as mais il ya le
cavalier en fait non ça va sauf qu'ils
jouent donc tourache lui toi je suis tu
menaces mat
donc il y croit en course parce qu'il a
ça marche pas tout simplement parce
qu'il ya cavaliers h 6 échecs sa bouche
toute tentative la dame va pouvoir
sortir on va pouvoir même gagné une
pièce en reprenant sur le cavalier aussi
avec échec guerrière seimat très rapide
on vous laisse d'ailleurs testé les
quelques matches et c'est un bon petit
ego il ya eu un couac à 3 kw à jouer un
exemple
alors qu'alexis on n'a pas le choix on
peut pas prendre avec le fou exemple de
coûts imaginons que les noirs jouent le
coup droit de 8 par exemple mais c'est
ma très vite puisque dame j'ai six
échecs avec 8 et matt bell partie très
belle partie une attaque qui a été
annoncé très rapidement
kotov annoncé la couleur c'est pas ce
qui est peut-être perdu un petit peu de
temps elle donne même beaucoup on a bien
vu d'ailleurs le c'est toujours pareil
dans les histoires d'attac de recomposer
comme ça enfin ou deux côtés opposés
on a vu d'ailleurs qu'on enlève l'enfant
attendu pour d'ailleurs le roi quasiment
pas bougé en fait de la partie
c'est le premier qui gagne quoi on peut
pas traîner premier arrivé premier servi
et l' avantage va souvent à celui qui
attaque le roi puisque ce sont des
menaces qu'il faut nécessairement paris
tandis que les attaques côté elle dame
pour spassky pour kotov été un petit peu
moins grave puisqu'il pouvait donner du
matériel en échange de la tacc de maths
qui était quand même brillamment menée
parce que c'était oui il fallait être
précis très apprécié dans l'est de la
sicile avec sa 10e
s'il ya effectivement il c'est ce genre
d'attaqué il ya une imprécision ça peut
par contre être un désastre après
puisque l' avantage matériel gagner de
l'autre côté par par les noirs peut
s'avérer décisif
donc voilà belle partie bon espace qui
est encore en pleine querelle temps à
près de s'améliorer mais on voit tout le
talent de coton dans cette partie et qui
surtout a été extrêmement cohérent du
début à la fin
il n'a pas il n'a pas hésité une seule
seconde il n'a pas il n'est pas revenu
sur son idée de départ
mais voilà pour cette partie de
alexandre alexandrovitch kotov
nous terminons cette rétrospective sur
ce joueur aujourd'hui
merci jérôme merci c'était fin et puis
je vous dis à bientôt sur les gones atv
pour d'autres retours son histoire des
grands champions d'échecs au revoir au
revoir